[Music]
who are you I'm daredevil
everybody is Charlie this is gonna be my
non-spoilery review of daredevil season
3 born again a return to form for a
kingpin
for daredevil for all the characters
like you guys had a lot of preconceived
ideas about what they were doing with
the season based on the comic book arc
they were adapting so well I'll try to
explain how well I thought that they
adapted it because obviously they had to
make a couple changes based on their
pre-existing Canon I've also got a hot
off the presses scoop that dropped while
I was making this review video Netflix
just cancelled iron fist officially so
I'll mention something at the end of the
video about this we're still doing that
spider-man ps4 game giveaway we'll leave
that open through most of the week all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video the story's all about Daredevils
metaphorical and spiritual rebirth
because he had the building dropped on
his face so he has to convalesce and
physically heal his body but he also has
to heal his soul and his spirituality
because he stops believing in justice
because of the kingpins arc there were a
couple critics complaining about the
Netflix bloat problem the first half of
the season the only reason why it wasn't
quite as big of a problem for me in this
particular case is just because it's
been so long since we've seen them so
they do have to spend a couple of
episodes setting up each person's
character arc and because it's Netflix
every single character gets an arc so
obviously you're mostly focused on
what's going on with daredevil and with
kingpin they also spend a lot of early
time setting up the Benjamin Poindexter
bullseye like he has to get to this
really crazy place by the end of the
season so they take their time starting
with a relatively normal-seeming person
struggling with a lot of problems his
and Matt's arcs are sort of parallel
because they're both spiraling out of
control obviously there's a lot of
visual metaphors about their arcs being
similar because he's pretending to be a
fake version of daredevil wearing his
costume fighting him in all the trailers
while at the same time kingpin is on the
rise in full command of his abilities in
fact he seems like the most sane person
the first half of the season everything
he's doing is very calculated Vincent
D'Onofrio has that really awesome creepy
calmness about him like you're just
waiting for him to explode which he does
a couple times to Grand affect
everyone's motivation feels very
authentic bull's eye is a little bit fun
here because he seems so crazy and all
the trailer footage that you've seen but
they do like I said put him on that arc
so that is believable by the time you do
have that big turn they do a pretty good
job of adapting Matt's comic book arc
the whole idea behind the comic book
born again kingpin crushing daredevil
and Matt Murdock's real-life identity as
a lawyer he has to find his faith again
in why it is that he does what he does
being a vigilante why do I wear this
costume so that's part of the reason why
he's wearing the black costume during
all this trailer footage when we pick up
he just doesn't feel like he deserves
any of that adoration or to wear that
costume his life has been all about
defending people in the courtroom and
defending people on the street when they
can't find justice in the courtroom but
because of the events of the last couple
seasons and defenders everyone that's
been close to him has been hurt so he
just feels like a complete failure so
that's why he goes back to basics so as
a seasoned daredevil season 3 the way
they write it is a return to basics
which I feel like is always good after a
couple years have gone by obviously this
is only the third season so it's a bit
of a weird situation I don't think that
that was planned you've probably heard a
lot of comments about why they aren't
rushing to do another Defender Series
mostly that's because people complained
about the pacing and because all the
main actors had to stop shooting their
spin-off shows all their individual
shows it brought everything else to a
grinding halt so the reason why we
didn't get daredevil season 3 sooner is
is because they had to go on this
character arc where Matt was believed to
be dead for a while they couldn't do
that till after they did the other
series so you start to see some of the
problems with the way they set the
structure of this series up so that's
why if they do do another defender
series Jeph Loeb implied that the roster
might be different it might be other
characters that become the defenders
that being said they do have tentative
plans for daredevil seasons 4 & 5 they
didn't say what those were I feel like
kingpin is hopefully o is going to be a
big part of the series they have not
screened episodes from the second half
of the season for critics yet so I have
no idea what ultimately happens to
kingpin this year but if you've read the
comic book story line you have a pretty
good idea of where daredevil ends up so
think about the way they ended Luke Cage
season 2 with that dark victory I'm
curious to see if they decided to do the
same thing for daredevil because for the
most part
they want you to think there's going to
be an optimistic ending to this and the
writers do a good job of putting you on
that roller coaster first they have to
crush Matt before he can build himself
back up again
so if he's after getting a building
dropped on his face during defenders was
all the crushing that was going to be
done no that's just the beginning of it
like I said there's a very predictable
pacing with these Netflix series usually
it's around episode six seven the
midpoint of the season when things
really go into crazy mode so that's why
the back half of the season usually
feels like the most exciting time
they've done a pretty good job with
their religious metaphors so far usually
those are on point it's not really hard
to hit because it's all written into the
comic maybe one of the reasons why
daredevil seasons and this season in
particular click really well on a story
level it's just because there's way more
quality stories to pull from in the
comic so it's not like the daredevil
riders are sitting around a table trying
to reinvent the wheel and I don't know
what it is with some of the series but
it feels like Jeff lobe because he's the
president of Marvel TV on a creative
level just has a better job of
understanding who the daredevil
character is and what he needs to be
people like Joe Quesada who's an
executive producer on all these netflix
series spent a lot of time writing
pretty decent daredevil stories so maybe
it's just one of those things where a
lot of the executives that make a lot of
the decisions just have spent a lot more
time thinking about daredevil their
entire lives and they've spent thinking
about the other characters so for
whatever reason if you've been
disappointed with the Netflix shows this
past season I feel like daredevil will
be your jam although a lot of people are
waiting for Punisher to come back
there's not a whole lot else I can say
to hype it up more the fight scenes are
a great I think daredevil vs. bullseye
probably my favorite fight scene just
because of the way bull's-eyes powers
work he has a taskmaster like ability to
study his targets he is obsessed as
you've seen in all the trailers so he
has to come up with counter moves for
all of Matt's Kunlun martial arts on the
fly
Netflix kingpin is every bit the fighter
as a comic book kingpin is but the way
they write him is is that he's sort of
like that silverback gorilla that just
sits there looking really menacing and
quiet and you're just waiting for him to
explode but the way they use him they
take advantage of his skills as a hype
man to rise to power without necessarily
always having to revert to his physical
strength so though you do kind of wait
for that daredevil versus kingpin
physical fight before the end of the
season I'm still hoping to see that
Vincent D'Onofrio as good as ever
probably the best Marvel villain in the
Netflix universe even one of the best
Marvel villains when you consider the
movie characters as well but I almost
forgot to talk about Joanne Whalley
she's playing mother Maggie who is in
the convent where Matt is convalescing
after defenders that's also the convent
where he was raised as a child so they
have a really interesting relationship
if you've read the comics you kind of
have an idea for what that is they
changed a couple things about their
backstory but the actress brings a
really nice energy there's a good
counterpoint to the energy that matt has
with father Atlantians character so she
and bullseye of course are my favorite
new characters in the season but once
you have a chance to see it everybody
let me know what you think of it in the
comments below what'll happen is is is
dropping Friday the 19th so I'll start
doing Easter eggs and more spoilery
videos after episodes start rolling out
if people have a chance to see it so no
worries the scuttlebutt about Iron Fist
being canceled is is that Netflix just
has so much content that they're pushing
out so they're in the stage of their
life cycle when they're okay with
canceling stuff so what will probably
happen is is if they had to a Moon
Knight TV show or a Ghost Rider TV show
that would actually probably go to the
Disney streaming service not to Netflix
I don't know if Marvel is gonna allow
any brand new characters to go to
Netflix so as for right now the existing
Netflix characters that they have are
safe they'll keep going for as long as
Netflix wants to renew their series my
next video will probably be my venom
Easter eggs while you wait for
everything click here for that new
spider-man far from home teaser and
click here to learn all about the new
armor that everyone's wearing in
Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you